yeah hello welcome to this broadcast I
hope I'm life and I will again ask if
I'm life even though someone pointed out
that it's no point in asking because if
the source software tells me and live I
should be live I know but it happened
that the software told me alive and I
wasn't so I will continue to ask quickly
ok cool it's life let's get going so I'm
not totally decided yet should I play a
bit more crazy stuff or should I play
like my usual boring self maybe I'll mix
it a little bit i'm going to request a
game and see what happens in mortal
let's go deform and see then maybe I can
spice it up a little bit like stuff like
that to the Trump which is kind of
middle of the road it's not crazy but
it's a little bit different than what I
usually do what about this I came to f3
+ e 40 it's not going for that so I have
to play 93 if I was an opening quite
similar to the black my Dima gambit I
would have gone for that whatever going
for now you see what is the big point
there don't I just have the center here
hmm ok so let's just develop that cannot
be really bad for me I guess what is
this idea does he want to go for a 5
p.m. I don't see it maybe just develop
here Bishop d3 92 i might play e5 kick
his night away b5 is normal that must be
nice for wide right someone requests the
Queens gambit declined with Bishop g5
haha ok with what color exactly
who someone says he studied the petrol
for two hours hmm that's a tough on
yourself now it's not Petrov is an ok
opening but still ok I want to prevent
before for the moment and then see what
happens yes the bishop on b7 let's get
this out of the out of the way and see
cannot somehow make sure that c5 is not
hitting I want to have d phi as a reply
cell play rook t1i a bishop g fire see
with white and the Queens gambit yeah
well I can try I mean I don't really
know that but I can play this how can i
make sure i'm at c5 i have d 5 he has
before possibly hmm maybe here for Queen
g3 at Bishop 2d6 before I can take plane
I'd be one maybe all night a4 before
night a form this is a bad idea he will
take I haven't it's interesting I can do
that he can take on a three but it's
probably interesting
now he might take on a three but I don't
know how good this really is for him his
structure is pretty dreadful after that
and I have ideas like Quincy three Queen
takes you for ok so it seems he wants to
take it hmm yeah yeah yeah I can go to a
sick song that's some problem hmm maybe
night c5 in this position it's an
interesting line i don't i don't really
know how good it is but it's interesting
ah ok mother any questions
there's a book pointed out to me on
Amazon about streaming on Twitch that's
fun yes streaming on Twitch yeah but
course it's a it's it's fun to do but
it's a matter of time management a
little bit if you do chess for a living
like I do it's a bit tricky to do those
kind of streams they take a long while
and they don't own any money and if you
if I do it on my free time there's a
limit of how much chest you can do a day
there are some some cases where I just
say okay it's enough chairs now let's do
something else um ok so I don't I did
not expect that move ok this is it's a
very simplistic way to play but not a
bad one taking their queen c3 tempo on
the bishop and then Quincy for that
gives right a slight advantage and I'm
content with that at the moment here he
has to move the bishop and then i take c
4 and that's nice for white i have the
better structure here let's see um where
do i get my night see you three Bishop
e7 leading to much I can also regroup
the night maybe this is better actually
yeah that's better now a 4 is just
prevented um ok
can still go here it looks a bit strange
actually but unharmonious here
threatening c3 how does he keep this now
c 3 okay now i can go c 4 4 C 5 or
possibly d5 so on up form and maybe I
should have gone to d3 actually okay
yeah how many hours do is spend on
teaching at post to making videos it's
not easy to say actually it depends a
little bit it's a it's basically a
full-time job so it's quite quite a bit
okay cYFD five takes chicks ok I have to
do that Bishop f6 I have to go Bishop b5
there's no big choice well we just
pushes ok I'm pushing myself here come
on the deep on looks dangerous and I'm
not sure that he does keep his a pawn
him
for rook be too and picking it up I
don't know what he does now this one
okay okay can check here now I can go
here and then pick up a two he's gotta
see poor now which is not good haha
difficult stuff
yeah 25 that's a kind of a problem chair
what can you do I'm still not sure about
this position the seaport is dangerous
true but I have some some play as well
yeah it's not very harmonious but i
guess i have to each was protected down
okay so hmm going back to g3 see 3 yeah
maybe the sea point is too much that's a
really a problem not easy Knight c3 Roxy
three wins so I have to do this not
before it's not yet happening Bishop can
go d 7 it's not helping though it's
still as night before so probably have
to cover that maybe you can take it to
play c2 okay you can do that that would
promote actually can i stop this pawn
I'm not sure about it right a form
I thought this pawns true I'm promoting
what is this a one on time I didn't even
see that Wow um wow they worse it was
difficult ok so I have a look there
there's a question about what I do with
students openings repertoire and I tend
to let them play what they want within
reason um after the group is not
acceptable yeah it's absolutely not any
any sound opening is ok I really don't
mind if they play something slightly
offbeat why not but it should be
fundamentally sound which an opening
like the group is not so I mean like
stuff like before let's sail move one is
very borderline yeah but i rather let
them want them to play some some more
mainline openings it's just better also
for learning chess if you play one
before all of the time for example a one
be three you simply only get two to
learn very limited part of chess the
iron chitara tech yep that's pretty
interesting and I keep I rubenstein ask
do you advise your students to play over
my end games absolutely do yep I've
Rubinstein and games feature very
heavily actually whenever I get to the
point to look at complex and games
Rubenstein is done quite often yeah I
tried to get games here but I don't get
something in the moment someone requests
the hippopotamus okay i can try let's
display the hippopotamus so this guy is
playing very
very very modestly yeah the Latvian I
don't allow simply it's it's just a bad
opening but it's easy to replace yeah if
you play the Latvian gambit and you want
something aggressive obviously against
one year for there are many things that
fit the bill for example the the llena
Schliemann gambit or stuff like that
it's easy to come from an opening light
let like the like the Latvian sorry and
switch that to a fundamentally sound but
aggressive opening it's easy in fact one
student of mine started with the Latvian
and now has gone to some some similar as
i said the Schliemann gambit and things
like that there are many aggressive
lines okay that's interesting here I
played the hippo and I don't really have
a bad position Wow that'sthat's crazy
that he lets me do this can take on g4
now the checking is Queen there 94
Bishop g6 Nazi to Bishop e8 they're just
not win material funny enough Knight f3
hmm that isn't so clear actually okay
let's do this just the tech f3 am but I
can take f3 here or move the rook let's
also not bad actually mmm do I move the
rook let's move the rook he's not
keeping a 3 there's no way to cover that
there's a question what do I think about
a 45 f 4d 5d for what that looks crazy a
counter counter gambit against the the
fork beer or fake bear don't don't
really think that's necessary okay can
can I go g5 take f3 or maybe just maybe
I can just take with the night down yeah
let's let's secure the Jeep on and then
take on a three that should be okay
books videos on the Schliemann gambit
there are two decent books there are
some the even Sokoloff book which has
all of the sidelines the Rue La Paz
revisited I think this is a book that I
had recommended in earlier streams and
there's also on the book attacking the
Spanish by sabina brunello they're all
okay star has as a starting point is the
hippo sound depends depends a bit on
white set up in the case what why did
here I think it's probably ok but well
it's still nothing that should be
recommended to for regular use okay so
that looks still quite nice but I maybe
should have played in a more aggressive
way I could probably let some of the
advantage slip but neither of three
coming still looks nice with made on h2
and I don't agree I don't think if white
knows what it's doing its falls apart
that that applies both to the hippo end
to the Schliemann the question if I like
Eric Schiller's books I don't have any
book by Erich Schiller so I know that he
has a rather dodgy reputation but
but I don't have any of his books okay
is so so what am I doing here maybe just
double on their farm ok so I can play
this to f8 as well and see what he's
doing ji oh it's all nice and good but
how do I actually win the game hmm how
do I actually win the game here can I
somehow increase pressure it's not that
easy actually surprisingly enough 5v5
maybe I have to switch their get the
night to a form how many chess books do
I have a couple of hundreds but I don't
really don't really know why I also
didn't know donated many books too much
as clubbin and I also lost quite a
couple simply due to oh he gave me this
was check that's quite helpful let's
let's take it and ask questions later we
actually resides um yep so let's see
there's a question what I do with my
students and it's it really depends a
lot on the student's level and that
strengths and weaknesses profile it's
difficult to say that's actually the
answer that that all chest teachers
would give you because it really is a
huge dis Julie it's a huge difference if
the student is like 2200 rated or 1500
rated or 1000 rated and to have all
those cases in in the case of them
to 1000 rated I would do completely
different things to the 2200 go in for
the stronger players like the master
level players it makes sense to study
some some serious openings give some
opening advise and so on it's
unavoidable to look at the opening quite
a bit under this level it's not the main
focus but it is it is part of the
lessons definitely while with people
that are let's say below 1500 I only do
opening opening principles lessons right
yeah how to how to exploit let's say
little development and things like that
um talking of openings what is this I
have no idea unfortunately before seems
to hit I wonder if this is an idea or if
this is bad 94 m and I can't go Bishop
g1 maybe Oh interesting hmm yeah yeah of
course if I check their takes on c3 yeah
that doesn't look too great but I cannot
really allow the night coming to d5
right now at night a 495 I probably have
to check them
hmm that looks rather uncomfortable I
have to say maybe this move I don't know
I'm inventing stuff here as we go along
okay mmm there's a question do you have
any GM norms or I am norms that would
count yeah I am norms don't really don't
really do much because i have this title
already for a while and I don't have any
Grandmaster norms and I never really got
closed one I mean had good events last
year but it was nowhere near a
grandmaster result okay um what am I
doing here like my position here maybe I
can take and like windy six just just
just keep it simple
yeah Bishop c6 queen bee sex was my idea
which is really simplistic and probably
way I don't have to play Queen be 60 que
habla should be seven as kind of an
annoying ok let's do that am i playing
any planning any tournament soon yeah I
actually I just played a tournament last
weekend but it was a very small event it
was my local clubs the championship of
my my hometown which really was a very
small tournament where I was a huge
rating favorite of about 400 points or
something and I won this event I'm just
conceding one draw ok it was mostly I'm
just for fun and about supporting my
club day a little bit um and I will play
one event in the summer I'm going to
play an open tournament in in in Poland
in Raj Slav i hope i'm not totally
killing the pronunciation there ok g 2
chapter 3 years of ugly moves but ok
let's sort of have to
yeah I may be posting one or two games
from that event it was very often the
case that I was very heavily ow traded
my opponent so it wasn't tough fight in
most cases but it had some the games had
some instructive definitely some
instructive moments here and there okay
I'm trying to get at his partner would
be eight as a bad idea to allow okay
maybe this move I want to get it as you
see ft 7 porn okay so here for f5 yeah I
mentioned last week that I think that
many of todd sacrifices were indeed
sound yeah they really were at least
very often they were good enough for
drawers and I really think that it is
very much an over exaggeration to say
that most of his sacrifices were unsound
or something every I don't do you think
that was the case yeah okay how did he
get his his attacking positions one
reason was that it simply was a
different time compared to today hui se5
now maybe huh I kind of Miss played that
here anyway but naughty five was
interesting I didn't do that I mean of
course he has a good end game in any
case but yeah and okay and what I wanted
to say is um times have changed to have
quad since the 60s and late 50s and one
reason was that at the time they simply
played different openings in some cases
for example if you look at this nowadays
almost nobody is is getting into super
sharp Sicilians anymore yeah from the
black side of course the Sicilian is
played but quite often in a in a far
more conservative way than it was in the
50s
there are the needles and stuff okay
night of line but in the 50s for example
they played very much very often they
played the classical Sicilian like the
rouser and the souls in variation with
with black and so on and this is
basically a extinct nowadays it's
absolutely not played and very often the
cases that it is not played because um
there are opposite side castles
happening where white has greater taking
chances and nowadays people just avoid
those lines and tall got tons of games
where he had those attacking chances and
if you gave him an attack he would
attack yeah and really really really I
mean he would attack very very very very
dangerously and this is not happening
nowadays quite often I think if you are
for example if you if you give Magnus
Carlsen who's got this reputation of a
very technical end game player and so on
if you give Magnus those kind of super
sharp attacking positions I'm not saying
he would play like tile that's that's
wrong but he would get taking games very
very often simply because the openings
permit that you don't get any attacking
games out of the Berlin it's just just
not happening ok I'm playing this I
don't know how but maybe not good but
maybe point is strong so I think with me
checking first I should have some
opportunities Queenie 5 check and ruby
three looks strong I cannot really
calculate I have no time but it should
there should be some kind of win here
Queen B 5 hmm
don't see you win amazingly okay take
this first check where's the win here I
don't see one will be six okay probably
this and check on the fifth this is not
made but I can win the rook okay here's
just one chicken Tina for I'm very long
one time there are K will probably win
on time he blundered the Queen okay I
unfortunately had to draw okay who that
was said was tricky okay I couldn't
really let me see can I de soucis more
here the life and games of me hotel it's
a great book if you really want to get a
good book and you don't don't have that
one the tab it's something to recommend
tollis writing in a very nice style it's
very it's a very good storyteller and
the games are obviously great so live in
games of me hotel very much to be
recommended okay ya head 20 28 seconds
left but it's kind of the way I play
this size 50 time control I am ok
let's get this going yep I'm requesting
a game but it's a bit slow at the moment
I'm sorry my noses tickling so let's see
I don't get a game at the moon I should
have won that of course but no time yeah
tile is telling that my most favorite
player yeah I don't know it really
changes it's changed a bit over the
years I really was a huge fan of crab
legs when he started to play and still
like his games but it's not not not as
pronounced as earlier no I totally
stopped smoking cigarettes and it was a
good decision in many ways yeah okay now
I get a game prince-bishop three two one
so I'm starting with if five and trying
to get some kind of attacking game going
maybe he will attack might happen might
happen I really don't have a favorite
player nowadays I really have to say I
don't have one I mean I got this
question quite a bit end I think I think
that I like aronian very much probably
also because of his opening repertoire
like e45 is also what I play I can
sometimes use ideas that that he plays
and as as answer to ask answered sm
asked earlier I really had don't don't
know why he is some in this crisis for
for quite a bit
there's there's a question out of 10
would I give what would I give myself in
tactics and what score in positional
play I don't know one to ten I already
don't know I know that I don't think I'd
get outplayed and strategically focused
positions much I really don't but in
tactics I quite often do smile loose my
Lucy orientation a little bit so I'm
definitely more of a strategically
focused player yeah i might play Knight
c4 here ok nazi for Bishop c7
there's a question what is some good
German beer hmm huh that's difficult I
mean as some of you know that either
like Guinness very much which is not
very much German um the area where i
live in is very close some very close um
I mean one of the main cities let me
phrase it like that is Dusseldorf and I
worked in this city quite a bit some
some years and they have a specific
brand of beer that's called IPA which
beer would be the literal translation
and I am kind of got to that a little
bit when when I work there it sort of
came with the territory so to say if you
work there you you got got this stuff
all the time and I kind of took a liking
to it but i also like quite as someone
someone mentioned also like the Bavarian
type of beer de the wheat beer or vice
beer yeah and especially am as you have
to quite often yet you you have to UM
what is he doing here night each form
maybe g6 you have to still a drive the
car I think I very much like those
non-alcoholic vice beer you know white
beer that's quite nice it's one of the
one of the few cases where you can
really get away with non-alcoholic beer
and in general the this this Bavarian
beer is a wheat beer or vice beers is is
really great if you are in Bavaria they
have many local brands and it's really
tasty and you can I mean it was really
amazing we have that here in my area as
well but we have that in my area as well
but the
the brands they are that they have in
Bavaria they're really there somewhat
yeah they are exotic from from our
perspective here you don't get them here
but really really good and we can
basically buy anything and everything
everything is tasty okay let's see I had
to give up the bishop there but okay I
have to you have to make compromises he
and depth okay so he doesn't mind to
trade this bishop and let's continue
them
okay there is some stuff there some
questions there's a question how do I
evaluate positions quickly yeah first of
all if i evaluate a position quickly it
might or might not be the correct
evaluation yet in blitz you have to be
quick and I'm not I'm not always right
of course um in general you have to be
you have to make quick judgments yeah
and most of it is based on patterns that
you know kind of comparison methods yeah
like this looks like it should be ok
because this piece is well placed or not
this kind of things it's difficult to
say it's very much about about knowing
patterns and compare them to what is
happening on the board there's a
question would i play auriga's over the
board yeah i actually have done that in
a blitz event then the over the board
german team bullets two years ago we
made a draw it was still I mean it was a
case where and at that time i already
have had this terrible score against him
I always had a terrible score against
him and so it was some yeah um it was
some funny funny that I had this game
there but in fact it wasn't I mean I
didn't have that many games on video at
the time so it wasn't a situation like
okay now I play the guy of that and so
on it wasn't such a pronounced situation
there what happens he actually it looks
what did I do I really had a nice
position there but I think I totally
screwed that up he's got F for coming oh
that's surprising why did he trade
queens
huh okay I don't get it Wow hey come on
buddy what are you doing to me
yes yeah someone asked about this game
against mr. illegals in over the board
yes he played in exactly the same
fashion he traded absolutely everything
to a totally drawn end game and shuffled
but it was it was really be drawn and
the the differences in from over the
board 222 online is that if I'm in shape
yeah and I have practiced a bit of blitz
then I'm really quick with my fingers
you know I'm really a quick player if I
want and he has absolutely no chance of
winning on time absolutely no chance oh
he quickly recognized that and we made a
draw but I didn't play on time I mean I
simply cannot do that even I mean I
don't so I was just it was just a draw
and ok and what again bishop age 5 or
picking up stuff now him so let's he
played in a very fancy manner yeah that
guy but I don't think it worked I could
just pick up everything here for for the
win
ok so is good age for that was supposed
bad why did I allow with that actually
okay well my be point is pretty quick
mie porn for that matter let's just push
the pawn them okay oops sorry I am he
defiles it's not a big problem but it
was a unnecessary mouse slip
and what did I actually allow that to
happen was necessary Queen age for mate
okay and okay let's see would you be
faster if you weren't commentating yes I
definitely would be faster but I think
it it's I'm the doing live commentary
from while while blitzing I mean I've
done so many of those live commentary
games I think the difference is getting
smaller and would you see Magnus
Carlsen's main strength this is superior
calculation abilities or is it his chest
stamina hmm I don't think I mean it
plays i think carlton has one particular
thing that I mean he has no very clear
weakness he sometimes just strange
things in the opening it really is still
happening that you don't really
understand what he does in the opening
but he has no particular weakness that
we can speak of and if we want to talk
about his his main strength I think he
has an extraordinary Liam developed feel
for where the pieces should be yeah the
simply the the kind of feeling where
things belong on the board yeah like
this piece should be there and well I
should maybe exchange this in that he's
in this in this particular regard he's
very similar to to cop off actually I
think he's some
quite comparable that that way to Kabul
it's um it's really uncanny sometimes
how well he evaluates where the pieces
should be in so it's really really great
and with that also comes this fantastic
endgame abilities and yeah I'm playing
into a line that I know exists c5 i
think is what they play Queen takes
something i don't know i really only
know that idea here 98 for f6 that's an
old game of car puffs but it's like from
the 90s so and someone requests i should
play some g3 Bishop g2 stuff maybe you
can do that my idea here is to play f6
and e5 so it's not let's go for that
it's not preventing it and I wonder I
could have played g5 v mm-hmm I don't
know ok c 4 is hanging let's grab the
pawn there's an older game cop off with
black against hat neck german GM Kings
gambit time someone says Kings gambit
I'm have a pretty disk with the Kings
gambit in online blitz I don't really
know why but it is not bad okay I can
take here now or is this too simplistic
v5 it's not a bad move actually I can go
with five why not
why am i overlooking stuff here the rook
on the seventh there could be could be a
problem 97 495 may be quite complicated
this position playing el jugador
jugadores the player in in Spanish which
I learned oh he's playing for trixia
okay I'm taking where there was a weird
way to phrase it playing for tricks
playing for tricks sort of sounds like
it would be bad what he's doing it it
wasn't it just he used the tactical
trick is what I tried to say but not a
bad one or anything okay so let's look
at this I was thinking this is an idea
activating the light and covering be aid
oh I completely overlooked that more
interesting okay it shouldn't be a huge
deal but take stinks ciao okay I can do
that it's not a big problem hookah p8p
should be eight i blundered this pawn
well it's not it's not a big problem i
have a pretty decent activity here he's
got two pawns they are see porn and a
porn and both are not moving this is
almost compensation for the pond not
quite but almost
yes what I said about cousins feel for
for strategy is pretty much what what
Kasparov said I was mostly get it wasn't
quoting him but it's essentially the
same opinion that I have them okay so he
tries to regroup the night so let's
prevent that and gain more space yeah
well this is funny right I mean here's a
pawn but I have pretty act pretty active
pieces not even sure if I would prefer
white at that point what is this idea
Roxy three maybe okay like I can I can
go back to a four it's no problem and I
can go g5f for nice so what is he doing
King be to wear that's not helping at
all I can just push stuff okay so ever
move the rock i have night a for coming
I can also check here now i can check
here night be 39 a form and king d force
in the mix but it's not that's not
helping much admittedly he has to move
the kingdom then i have night a for
though for taking on c4 that's nice yep
let's take it
and look be to wear which is even more
of a problem sometimes yeah I had a good
compensation for the pawn for some
reason ok rugby to King back and 95 just
keeping the whole position I wonder if
that's better than taking one c4 take on
c4 I don't know if I should make a move
should make a move I really wasn't sure
about this
not good didn't think about that move
and it's a good one
92 can take c4 all right let's use this
pawn Oh quite tricky right quite tricky
I don't really see what he's doing oh
he's giving me this is a losing
straightaway right it's made even wow
that's what's so surprising i know the
game but it was very active I don't know
okay so the four pawns a check of the
Kings Indian is it unsound hmm now I
don't think so it's just that um it is
some pretty okay for black there are
some some lines that should be quite
okay four pawns is a line that can be
recommended for an aggressive white
player why not but you have to invest
some time to play it it's not something
that can be just played and on general
grounds or whatever it's very very sharp
stuff yeah the end of the game here was
very very mystifying um okay okay
playing at home rot here from GM this is
grand master key largo here think he did
he recently win one of the senior events
I don't know yeah he's he has a very dry
playing style as we will see here take
on d 2 and so on this line is some very
very solid for black hmm but this is in
fact okay it's still a solid line but at
least he's doing something here I'm
going to know it's not going to hanging
pawns okay so what is this actually
before maybe not sure about this it's a
big uncommon that I have the look on see
one down so a 4 4 a 5
let's do that and not try to get into
huge time trouble okay let's go for a
five it's a bit of a strange way to play
it but okay um ah ok that's a way to
play this of course so let's take how is
he going to play then let's just play
here and see well I have some play
against be six years play against a form
how do I get this somehow improved maybe
the bear up here I don't I don't really
know I guess be five hmm maybe I should
have taken care that yeah it's not that
bad actually because of this little
trick now I've attacking the the bishop
there and there's a question do I ever
play the Sicilian as black if not why
yes I played played the Sicilian yeah I
played it many lines actually not just
one I played quite a bit of the
specially call for example I also played
the night off so one of my first
openings um it is some i play the
Sicilian occasionally nowadays but it's
really more of occasionally as a word
and the thing is that I I don't have
that much time for my own opening study
now it's just that isn't 95 like killing
him I don't see any move then I really
don't have much time for my own opening
study as I focus on teaching and the
Sicilian is of course an opening that
really has to be studied with many
concrete lines
and it's um it's difficult to play just
on general grounds and who this makes it
difficult I sometimes play it if I feel
the opponent is it's feeling you know
but not on a regular basis many sicilian
lines are of course totally fine me now
i experimented a bit with the the
Kalashnikov which is also a fine line
many many good ones so if you are happy
with a sicilian of course play it um
it's just that i tried out various
various things and um one problem with
some Sicilian lines is for me personally
that lets say the night off is of course
grade but but you sometimes get you
sometimes get situation that's in the
night off where they attack your king
quite quite heavily and I don't like to
get attacked I'm a king I like to have a
safe King and it's their form I am more
inclined to play e5 and yeah there's a
question this after book slay the
Sicilian by Jim Taylor do I recommend
that yeah I still recommend that book it
has some flaws with some lines but it is
a very good starting point for a
somewhat slower approach to the Sicilian
it's still the opens the same but it was
Bishop e2 I like that so it's quite
quite a good alternative to more more
brutal more brutal lines let's say yes
this recent book by Tony rotella is
quite quite good on the Kalashnikov
how to refute the group yeah you know if
you are if you are a member of the ICC
it's a good idea to just watch the video
there by John Watson yeah about he has a
serious now about irregular openings
where he shows how to combat the group
on the other hand the group is an
opening well you never get it and to
invest lots of time there's really
useless if you have an opponent who
place that I mean play common sense
moves so that's really a really a good
idea if you really feel on you want
something simple if you play this assay
and you can easily play c5 playing the
salient style and well just occupying
the center cannot be bad so just play
good common sense chest and you will be
totally fine against her and offbeat
opening like the group I think even g4
h5 is pretty good but it's not something
that I really can claim to have any
knowledge about because it's really a
never looked at this opening and I never
got it in an actual game in 25 years of
tournament chess yeah someone is is
asking about the book porn power and
chess by Hanscom oh yeah that's a funny
book Comeau has all those funny funny
names for things for motifs and and
stuff um yeah I don't know I think it's
pretty a bit a bit outdated that was a
cheater and yes but he played an early
d3 so I'm excused for that
okie dokie so I'm going to put this one
on these six and I should make sure not
to get mated on the H file that can
happen I shouldn't blunder the night
only five those things yeah that should
that should work yeah and someone
mentioned that in the grope you can you
can sacrifice the exchange yeah you can
that's actually one of the problems this
there is a line we're sorry widest some
winning the exchange and in fact this
isn't even so great ok let's get this
back I don't like to have the night on
the rim all the time the night comes to
d5 hmm Jerry 97 it's not what I wanted
but ok you can't have it all
yeah I really think that comic book is a
bit outdated and those are those funky
names that he has for stuff I don't know
if this is really leading to much to
learn those nobody will understand what
you're talking about anyway if you tell
someone this is the quad group or
something you might sound very
sophisticated but they will mostly look
like totally puzzled okay this is a
final game by the way it's um I'm online
for one hour okay try to provoke the f3
move there let's see I think I should be
okay in this position I don't really
feel under big threat here he might line
up against age six porn but I don't know
if this is really coming okay let's
trade stuff er no Kings gambit yeah I
didn't get to get to one and nobody
played it against me yeah what about
this can i somehow get to the d5 pawn at
least I played this quickly I'm tho
those who know past positions yes and
there's a book mentioned pawn structures
in chasm it's actually it'sit's book and
it's pretty good um John the follow me
you did a video review on the book and
he was very positive i think i did not I
did not watch the video and it was a
case where John actually did something
that I intended to do it's not that he I
mean I'm not accusing have anything that
it's just that we both obviously have
the book we both like it I wanted to
make a review but he was just quicker
um it's pretty nice it's pretty nice
it's a good a good overview on porn
structures and especially a good
starting point if you are new to a
certain structure it's very helpful okie
dokie yeah this is kind of yeah it's
kind of it's kind of boring this
position can I do something though I
mean I can try maybe I can get this
Bishop traded that's an idea actually
maybe this kind of thing I mean I have
the bettors better structure there okay
a five hmm let's it's nice I have some
some chances here it's nothing great but
it is some chances so probably a four
here it's probably a draw but i can i
can try a bit some should up here so
it's there a way to try to win i can
remove king to f5 can try to enter via a
4 maybe this is an idea i don't know on
any s called f4 check that's not good
for carrots put here put it here i can
shuffle a bit i don't have a clear idea
yet well maybe I can go G for now I
think that's a good idea that's still
very Jewish
hey it's still very Jewish maybe if I
get around to this to h4 g3
let's let's keep this checked hmm
probably nothing going on here auntie a
skinny for I really have to be a bit
cautious that I'm not allowing something
that is hitting back on me okay well Kim
he keeps offering drawers but I don't I
don't really see that is that this is a
clear draw here I really don't know if
this this wasn't wrong I'm not like I
wasn't playing on time in this in this
game it also risking stuff here by
giving away stings so cheeks here I
don't have a clear the deep pawn is
quite strong I know ah Mau slipping
route I know what a bad Mouse slip
that's terrible and losing a total and
losing a complete tempo in this that's
really terrible yeah I winning on time
here but i think it was it was probably
we're not losing a template was probably
winning i'm not sure i'm really not sure
okay so are there any final questions
there yeah how do how do you evaluate
material imbalances yeah that's very
difficult of course and a matter of
experience and training there is no
clear there is no clear recipe for that
there's a question do I think it's
impossible to achieve I am level if you
started playing when you were 30 years
old um it's very very unlikely i don't
think there's and there's a case where
this was achieved but i wouldn't i
wouldn't rule it out totally but the the
likelihood is very very low it's simply
that you're the mental capacity is
really not going up over time and 30 is
pretty it's pretty late the things that
you have to yeah memorized the patterns
and so on i think they are really more
easily learned when you when you are
much younger but well this it's always
it's possible to really achieve a decent
level of play that is quite quite clear
but i am it's pretty high i mean it's
it's doable of course i'm not saying
that it's it's impossible for for a
certain player but 30 is it's a bit term
it's a bit as a bit late how much time
did I study per day to become a master
it's difficult to say but I did a lot
really a lot yeah more than you can
imagine probably okay guys this is like
more than one hour and it's not just me
it also has to be monitored by the
assessee so i just cannot stream for
hours and hours and on i hope you
enjoyed it and i'll be back next Monday
same time same yeah same website
everything is going to be repeated next
week I hope also the score pretty
wellness this is evening ok guys thanks
for watching
you